wie alt er ist glaub netz willkommen
beim ein video
ja aber ich habe heute nach keine ahnung
wie lange zeit mal wieder mein bruder
dabei das geschäft ist gut zu tun als
uns leute was besonders weil ich oder
was besonders das gab's immer von mir
und zwar vor einer woche oder so dass
videos abgegangen und ihr wolltet
unbedingt im zweiten part und zwar bin
ich auf die idee gekommen das alter von
euch zu erraten
andy ist nicht mitbekommen haben ich
habe euch aufs netz und installiert so
verschicken auch mal ein foto von euch
mit eurem alter und mein mitbewohner
also zu hause bei mir in köln der appell
ist halt immer vorgehalten und ich mal
schätzen die alte sei das war echt mega
witzig weil es einfach zu schwer
heutzutage zu sagen ob mädchen oder ab
und sorgen junge jetzt noch 13 oder 14
und da kommen wir jetzt total witzige ja
vergleich bestanden
deswegen gibt es einen zweiten partner
fahren ich habe mich heute allerdings
das ganze ein bisschen anders victory
das hier soll ein lager aus mainz wie
kann man das machen jeder vier bilder
aufgelöst was ist wohl der sinn davon
hatten ja aber als kleines challandes
natürlich also es geht darum ich habe
die bilder ausgesucht beim 104 bilder
ausgesucht wir werden uns halt
gegenseitig diese bilder zeigen und der
erhalt mehr richtig errät hat am ende
gewann machten
ok ich glaube der erste fahrt hiervon
hat von 50.000 leicht oder so da sitzt
auch neigt ich weiß nicht mal sehen wie
ich vielleicht wie hier schaffen und
natürlich auch weiter über dazu für noch
einen dritten partner sohn und ich will
sagen wer anfängt schnick schnack
schnuck nicht auf angst verbreiten gute
bilder er das erste fotos echt
kritisches bereich
so wird was stellst du dir das mal was
also wird zu sagen so er noch jünger
oder schon älter
14 14 15 was jetzt 14 15 15
weiterhin 0 0
ich kann jetzt ihr das 1 0 erzielt was
stellst du dir den dass auf jeden fall
nicht leicht wird einfach mal sagen 13
11 11-11 aber die beach man eigentlich
also sie konnte schon rein aus dass wir
weiterhin 90
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt das ist
einfach glaube ich mit einem einer
älteren ältesten zuschauerin was sätze
wie alt die älteste ja also was willst
du kannst ja mal wieder sieht sie auch
so viel zu sagen du musst nicht wirklich
den tipp abgeben aber erstmal was spart
für sie so vom bauchgefühl her sagen
20 20 und wie viel text du also 19 19
okay leute um den dreisten beide
durchfällt sie ist einfach blätter tipp
20 17 in einem jahr ok in mainz 19
bergleute sieht einfach 29 ich will
jetzt mal interessieren ob irgendwer von
euch der mich halt aktiv schaut noch
älter ist dann lasse ich das auf jeden
fall meinen kommentaren wissen die alte
seite 43 muss ich das bild im 50 okay
leute ist weiterhin 0 0 das läuft ja
echt gut wir können ja richtig gut
beraten hier und sagen zu wählen der
erste junge er sieht aus wie ein typ ich
würde sagen er fünfter
nein es gibt so nicht okay ich hab noch
weitere heftige das ist also die die
letzte dichte zeige die ist echt das ist
richtig heftig da bin ich draufgekommen
aber das ist kein beck 100 prozent auf
insgesamt 50.000 voller segen kann es
keinen zweck werden so wir machen weiter
mit person nummer 33 12 16
sie ist einfach 18 wir haben jetzt drei
gezeigt es steht immer noch 0 0
also leute 2009 wir sind echt super
super starke leistungen dass ihr okay
was glaubst du wie auf dem feld
die machen einfach mal so das kann man
gar nicht sagen aber die nase nicht
sieht
ich habe jetzt zwei mal falsch gelegen
weil sie mag ich zu alt gesagt habe ich
sag jetzt dies hier sind 1 0 bestrafen
ist übrigens heute ich darf den hund
schützen
ich bin mir sicher ich habe eigentlich
schon gewonnen weil das land jetzt kommt
es zu heftig das ist wirklich noch
heftiger als im netz video meiner
meinung nach und du musst jetzt erwarten
weil wenn es nicht erreicht und hat
schon gewonnen aber da muss man trotzdem
lacht den meisten fällen meister bekommt
also theoretischen unentschieden
erreichen so ich kann ihn sogar zweifel
davon zeigen was wirst du wie alt
ich hätte dann eben wieder vierte sagte
warte warte hier das bild zeigt ihr und
das besser ich dir 14 fraktionsmitglied
15 15
über lecks noch mal gut an wieder 14
findet die sich nicht auf die acht
jahren und neun jockey kieren fallon ich
sagen so denn ich hätte alles mit nokias
mit den 15 selina person des
öffentlichen lebens bremer kurier ins
profil ein damit jetzt wirklich seht
hier zwischen sie ist halt wirklich 14
und ihr könnt ja mal vorbei schauen
schreibt bei unterjähriger schöne müsse
von alex auf jeden fall egal kraft wenn
ihr euch die bilder anschaut sieht echt
überhaupt auf keinem einzigen fotos die
fehlt meiner meinung nach also der
kinder schon mal gewonnen
jetzt dachte mir natürlich noch das
letzte foto von ihr zeigen weil dann
kann ich natürlich noch mal das ich hier
wirklich eindeutig besser will heftiges
auschwitz 15 14 14 14 seit irgendwie
eine gute zahl
hierzu ist der gute teil glaub ich war
zweimal geil so sieht sie haben wir hier
gespielt hat manchmal das endergebnis
204 nicht als würfel etwa drastisch
gefallen hat ich hoffe ihr habt auch
kräftig mit geraten in den kommentaren
80 100 wir noch ein paar und wir sehen
uns dann am dienstag wieder mit neuen
video folgt auf meinen bruder gern auf
instagram ich auch noch kurz ein profil
ein netter weise könnt ihr mir
vorbeischauen und mir natürlich auch
snapshot und installierter wichtig wie
windows
wer wissen müssen diese jetzt einmal
gegen die kamera und damit verweisen